[Música]
algunos les pasó que al momento de
hablar en público le tiemblan tanto las
piernas que casi no le salen las
palabras a quien le pasó levante la mano
o algunos les pasó que por ahí en esa
situación les palpita tanto el corazón
que parece que les va a salir por la
boca
a mí me pasó una vez hace 15 años me
está pasando ahora pero bueno quédense
tranquilos que no voy a salir corriendo
me voy a quedar aquí ya ves hace 15 años
yo daba clases en la facultad y me
convocaron para dar el curso de ingreso
sobre metodologías del estudio como
siempre me puse a preparar el curso
prepare el mate encendí la computadora
pero esa vez algo era distinto en mí
cada vez que me ponía a preparar ese
curso
aparecían unas voces en mi cabeza y me
empezaban a decir
esto le vas a dar a los alumnos de la
facultad pues crees que le vas a aportar
algo y cada vez que me ponía a preparar
ese curso aparecían mis amigas las voces
yo hacía como que no las escuchaba pero
yo sabía que estaban ahí finalmente
llegó el día de empezar el curso
llegué me puse en el escritorio pero esa
vez el aula me parecía más fría que de
costumbre entraba un alumno otro alumno
y cada vez que entraba un alumno mi
corazón iba más rápido
hasta que llegó el momento de empezar
lance la pregunta que esperan del curso
y a partir de ahí no escuché nada más lo
único que escuchaba era mi corazón y las
voces de mi cabeza que no paraban de
hablarme hasta que de repente una voz me
sacó de mi trance era un alumno estaba
en el primer banco pablo pablo levantó
tímidamente la mano y empezó a decir yo
creo que el curso me va a ser útil lo
que empezó a decir pablo mágicamente me
rescató de mi rollo mental y empecé a
conectarme con lo que decía él con lo
que decían sus compañeros esta
experiencia fue un gran aprendizaje para
mí y a partir de ahí empecé a averiguar
qué es esto del miedo escénico y
encontré un montón de definiciones pero
encontré una que me definía de punta a
punta el miedo escénico es una respuesta
psico física del organismo generalmente
intensa ar a pensamientos anticipatorios
catastróficos sobre la situación real o
imaginaria de hablar en público
pensamientos anticipatorios
catastróficos yo dije esas son las voces
de mi autoexigencia esas son las voces
de mi cabeza pero que catástrofes me
estaban anunciando mis voces era que se
me cayera el pecho encima que me quedara
sin voz que salieran corriendo los
alumnos no lo que me estaban anticipando
las voces de mi autoexigencia eran
catástrofes relacionadas con mi imagen y
mi reputación
y me puse a pensar de dónde vienen estas
voces y encontré tener tres grandes
dueños de las voces de mi autoexigencia
el primero yo soy psicopedagoga y hace
muchos años atendía en el consultorio
tenía varios pacientes en esas
situaciones también aparecían las voces
de mi autoexigencia pero lo que me
decían era distinto en esa situación
frente a alguna intervención que tenía
que hacerle algún paciente me decían que
le hubiese dicho freud a este paciente
que le hubiese dicho lacan a este
paciente
puede parecerles exagerado pero les juro
que era real
siempre me parecía que había alguna
intervención mejor siempre me parecía
que alguien podía hacerlo mejor y
probablemente fuera cierto pero eso no
me ayudaba ni a mí ni a mis pacientes
el segundo dueño de la voz es está
científicamente probado que el
aprendizaje es mucho más profundo si
nosotros podemos capitalizar los errores
y también está claro que podemos ser
innovadores y creativos si nos animamos
a equivocarnos pero cuánto nos cuesta
equivocarnos
cuánto nos cuesta asumir la posibilidad
de equivocarnos pero que le tenemos
tanto miedo piense en cualquier
situación salvo que esté en nuestras
manos la decisión de desactivar la bomba
y elegir entre el cable rojo o el cable
azul la verdad que las consecuencias no
son tan graves sin embargo para nosotros
son gravísimos porque
porque sentimos que en cada error se va
nuestro ser nuestra identidad casi toda
nuestra reputación
sin embargo cuanto más nos focalizamos
en el posible error más riesgo de
equivocarnos
el tercer gran dueño de las voces la
necesidad de tenerlo todo bajo control
de saberlo todo sobre un tema de
anticipar todas las variables y podemos
manejar todas las variables en todo lo
que hacemos yo creo que la verdad que no
sin embargo nosotros muchas veces nos
vemos empecinados en un perfeccionismo
casi imposible que nos lleva a dar
vueltas a dudar de todo
y nunca nos focalizamos en el objetivo
de lo que tenemos que hacer
y hasta que ustedes se preguntarán bueno
cuando viene la parte que nos cuenta
cómo hacer para apagar las voces no
lamento desilusionarlos nunca encontré
la perilla para pagarlas definitivamente
y creo que nunca las voy a encontrar
pero si aprendí varias cosas lo primero
es que cuanto más consciente soy de
estas voces y cuanto más me animo a
desafiar las menos peso tienen en mí
lo segundo es porque pablo en aquella
clase hace 15 años fue tan importante
para mí fue importante porque fue lo que
me permitió conectar con el otro porque
cuanto más conectada estoy con los otros
cuanto más conectados estamos con los
otros y con la tarea que tenemos que
hacer con nuestro propósito y el
objetivo de lo que queremos hacer
automáticamente las voces de nuestra
autoexigencia baja en el volumen
lo tercero lo aprendí charlando con un
amigo él me decía bueno pero la
autoexigencia al final es lo que te
ayuda a ir para adelante a agarrar
nuevos desafíos a lograr tus metas yo no
puse a pensar a ser así
será que la única forma guiado por la
autoexigencia entonces me puse a pensar
cómo son los procesos cuando nos dejamos
llevar por la autoexigencia y la verdad
es que los procesos son bastante
frustrantes desmotivante si no la
pasamos nada bien entonces debe ser que
la única forma
de desafiarse motivarse lograr metas es
pasándola mal yo creo que no creo que
hay otra forma
porque en nosotros hay otras voces
además de las voces de nuestra
autoexigencia si nosotros nos animamos a
escuchar esas voces que son la de
nuestra auto-confianza y nuestro
potencial el proceso puede ser distinto
puede ser mucho más placentero y podemos
lograr los mismos objetivos esas voces
lo que nos dicen es totalmente distinto
nos dicen
deja de escucharte a vos misma deja de
estar pendiente de tu imagen
confía confía en vos
que lo que hagas si lo haces con pasión
y con honestidad vas tener un buen
resultado y si te equivocas no pasa nada
grave esas voces también están en
nosotros
el desafío está en elegir qué voces
queremos escuchar
[Aplausos]
[Música]